what's the purpose of this individual
building a long-term relationship with
you is the biggest thing because you can
either be a numbers recruiter where
we'll go to that business because we'll
get 10 CVS like hire a candidate through
them but you've got the consultant LED
recruiter where you are an industry
expert and by articulating what in tasso
does as a business yes you need your
personal branding around time Jamie this
is what I do this is my market this is
what natasso does in the cyber security
ecosystem the thing we try and instill
across the team is it's not a candidate
it's not a client you know it's a
customer cool